stars of june are typically grads and
dads right so if you're looking for a
thoughtful luxurious and discounted gift
for your loved one max pawn luxury has
you covered so pawn broker tracy butchko
is here to help us start our shopping
list wow i already want everything and
i'm neither a dad or a grad
that's not fair
it's just not fair okay let's start with
graduation what are some things people
are coming in the store looking for for
further grads there's always a large
selection of different types of items
that you might not normally think about
like watches or
if it's a woman we've got a large
selection of handbags and we do
beautiful jewelry
okay well let's start with the let's
start with the backpacks here this is a
beautiful so i know this ensemble right
here the the blue and monogram
louie the backpack and the duffel i mean
who wouldn't love to travel with that
and yes of course
i know look at that it's now i mean you
need to book a trip
okay beautiful all right let's get to
all of these items here yeah so thinking
about dads and grads we brought a little
selection of what we just a very small
sampling we've got of course the tom
cruise aviators oh kendall where are you
but we also dreams come true wallet
hermes crocodile wallet
some money clips that i know a lot of
people aren't carrying cash anymore but
this is great to slide your debit card
your id and there you go there you go
there you go that's perfect for dad or
your grad and of course watches i think
coming of age gift right yeah i think we
were talking today with another person
and it you're a watch person or not a
watcher right right you'll never catch
me without a watch okay and you'll never
catch me with one
and my husband said the same thing like
never buy me a watch it's a waste right
but for the people that love watches we
have a huge selection our owner is great
at being able to procure any watch you
can pretty much think of that he knows
what he's doing he knows what he's doing
and last but certainly not least i gotta
i'm gonna put this down and show off my
shoes can you guys see my shoes
my yeezys these are max pond purchased
okay so let's talk about shoes i know
right we have a huge selection of shoes
runners and all kinds these are retro
11s in a size 12. with the original box
these are the space jams
so already someone's trying to buy them
online but they're not trying to pay
full price so we're like
exactly you know exactly these are
pretty hot right now what size did you
say size 12
just just a little too
you know okay so with all of that said
everything is certified authentic tell
us how you guys do it at max pawn look
so all of our luxury handbags um are
going to come with a tag like this one
this is through a third-party
authenticator called entropy
entropy takes microscopic photos of your
bag the material the hardware the
stitching the logos runs it through
artificial intelligence and tells us if
the bag is authentic i love it thank you
so much i love max pawn you guys have to
stop by the store and we'll be right